what's the deal with everything peanuts
all right listen to me
[Music]
the culmination of daytime Chrissy's
about to happen I am co-hosting the 9
A.M hour I mean you can eat them up
literally right there it is yeah but you
give me diarrhea buddy lactose
intolerant
[Music]
breaking news baby has anybody seen only
murderers in the building yes um no I've
seen them outside the building
um that's New York
today is Monday October 31st and Chrissy
co-host was in full effect this
Halloween with Chris's Stefano
co-hosting the Fox 5 Morning News show
earlier today welcome back to the joke
World comedy update every single Monday
bring you all the comedy news that you
need to know from your favorite
comedians your favorite podcasts
literally anything important happening
in the comedy world all on one YouTube
channel on one place so if you want to
stay in the loop please consider
subscribing to joke world right now turn
on the post notifications so you don't
miss anything and download this episode
on Spotify or apple podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts if you feel like
supporting the show
you look ridiculous I love it look at
this time look at us this is a good song
it's called Dead Mom good title so
Chrissy chaos was Chrissy anchors this
morning going on TV to host the news in
his big wiener costume this wasn't
Chris's first time on Channel 5 he did a
pretty funny interview with them back in
March when he was promoting his comedy
special especially weshi hello hello I'm
a little nervous with you here don't be
nervous okay here's what happened here's
how I got on to sit with the lovely
Rosanna Scotto is about a month ago I
was drinking in my uh house alone I was
drinking martinis watching in Kanto with
my children and I said I'm going to
Tweet Rosanna Scotto you up at three
o'clock in the afternoon and then she
wrote back about eight hours later she
goes are you and I was like I love this
lady and then I said I'm gonna make it a
point I'm going to email I'm going to DM
do you even know what you want means Joe
is that dirty it's yeah well I mean why
would you do that because I was drunk
watching in condo what else am I
supposed to do in this current age of
podcasts and comedians operating more
independently than they ever have it is
cool to see Chris estefano going on a
show like this for no real reason really
other than just to be funny like he's
not promoting anything specific he's
just going to share his humor with a
more broad audience I feel like with
comedians having to rely on networks
less and less there's not as much
pressure to go on these talk shows and
morning news shows in general let alone
go on and conform to their type of Clean
Comedy so these guys are going on and
just being themselves letting their
jokes fly and it's cool to see as a fan
are you going to behave or what no okay
just seriously throw me out now because
I will ruin your life today is Halloween
obviously and a few podcasts decide to
get in the spirit go with the theme of
Halloween and dress up for their latest
episodes including bad friends hey babe
we might be drunk and more everyone say
who they are Bobby go I am Jeffrey
Dahmer is one of his victims the
Filipino guy he ate no I'm I'm Elvis
Presley how you doing this guy over here
is my good friend Elvis Presley how are
you doing Dad why don't you eat one of
the sandwiches I made for you
that's real that's really good what does
he say that's just uh it's some fish I
cooked earlier that's why it smells over
there it's not because of young black
men's bodies rotting in the fridge yeah
it stinks because I'm I let some meat go
bad
so good I really messed it up this time
huh Dad yeah oh Dad I'm in a real
stinker now
that's so good he would kill someone and
they go
kicker this time
I'm in a real conundrum
it's almost like uh Jeffrey you severed
his head yeah too many crickets I never
knew it was gonna come to this what
thank you yeah he's waiting for that oh
yeah Peters all right we are [ __ ]
virgins huh
holy [ __ ] speak for yourself I'd clean
up in Japan right now
Dan soda's with us a boy yeah our boy
for so long we've been tight with him
for so many years this is fun dude
Millions Netflix HBO Comedy Central the
bonfire bonfire
every time you say my credits I gotta
eat it like a coin
personally I think stavi ran away with
the comedian's costume contest this year
with his naked Darth Vader but let's put
it to a vote in the comment section hear
all the costumes again so vote one two
three or four for who had the best
costume this Halloween and will announce
the winner next week alright shaffir's
newest stand-up special titled Jew is
coming out later this week on YouTube
Adam and Eve if you guys know that story
okay if you know that story this is all
gonna go over your head tonight
here's what happened in six days God
created the world on the seventh day he
rested you guys remember this one uh and
then later God went to Adam he's like
Adam how do you like it here how do you
like the Garden of Eden and Adam's like
oh dude I love it it's awesome plenty of
sunshine tons of animals to [ __ ] this
place is sweet
that guy was like wait bro are you
[ __ ] all the animals
I was like not all yeah you made a lot
of apples
foreign
by the way I killed a frog on Tuesday uh
yeah his eyes were bigger than his belly
they're right open am I bad on that one
said God was like [ __ ] dude stop [ __ ]
the animals right now
and so Adam was like who should I [ __ ]
that and God's like yeah good question
fair enough
he's like tell you what I'll make
another person for you to [ __ ] humans
should [ __ ] humans So Adam with no
concept of women right there never been
a woman ever in history before so when
he heard another person who's coming he
was just like sweet another dude I can
[ __ ] in the butt nice too foreign
was like no you assume wrong
it'll be like a dude but it'll have like
a
like a front butt
and you can [ __ ] the front butt yeah
I love that idea he was like sweet I
could [ __ ] the front butt and the back
butt
the full special officially drops on
Wednesday November 2nd and will be
available on Ari shaffir's YouTube
channel the clips he's put out for
promotion so far look really good so if
you're a fan of Ari I'd be very excited
for Jew guest spots from last week your
mom's house talked with Al Franken two
bears one cave was Burton Tom and Bert
whiskey Ginger had on Fortune fiendster
flagrant did not have a guest they're
still talking about Kanye West kill Tony
tonight is with Dave Attell Ian finance
and Eric Griffin film from skank Fest
and Mark Norman was on are you garbage
Halloween yes you got that right no
candy corn please
the worst that's crazy talk yuck chalky
waxy gross I don't mind it in very small
I had like a one Handful in this season
that'll be it I love here I love it I
like the pumpkins too the Candy Corn
pumpkins those are better the whole nine
yards I'm all about it what did you what
what did you do as a kid for a house you
had like a traditional house to house it
wasn't a great neighborhood right no we
lived in a rough area so we'd go to my
friend's house in the suburb and the
parents would kind of lag 10 feet behind
sure they would all skip to the Loo with
our little land uh jack-o-lanterns
although I did a schwegman's bag which
is our grocer okay plastic bag or yeah
grocery bag double bagged and uh you
know you you Dre I always did the uh I
dressed up too late and just would put
something on one time I put on a vest
and my friend's like what are you I'm
like I'm a spy
I'm a gay spy obviously yeah this past
weekend and Theo Von had on Andrew
Callahan Nikki Glaser was on tigerbelly
Joe Rogan talked with Dr Phil we might
be drunk out on Dan Soder and Bill Burr
was on the Tim Dillon show probably
episode of the week brand new standard
of specials out recently we already
talked about this one but Ari shaffir
Jew comes out in two days November 2nd
that will be on YouTube and it will be
for free and then Gabriel Iglesias stand
up fluffy on Netflix with the
description reading a funding and
professional boxer trick-or-treating
with his son Gabriel shares his highs
and lows in this Landmark stand-up
special that was filmed in Dodger
Stadium it's pretty badass big big event
so go check that out on Netflix and also
just one thing with the stand up special
segment I'm not purposely leaving out
any of these specials it's just hard to
come across these so if you have any
specials that you think need to be
included in this anyone releasing stuff
independently on YouTube that you think
is a worthy special that needs some more
eyes on it please let me know in the
comments that does it for this week's
joke World comedy update as always thank
you so much for watching and we'll be
back again next Monday with some more
comedy news but in the meantime we'll be
posting some other comedy related videos
on this channel so please make sure to
subscribe to joke world right now to
stay in the comedy Loop and go download
this episode on Spotify or apple
wherever you listen to podcasts to
really support the show if you want even
more comedy in your life go follow us on
Instagram we'll post comedy content on
there all the time and if you DM us
we'll even send you some free joke World
stickers not a better deal than that in
the world free
are you kidding me thanks for watching
we'll see you later this week or Monday
happy Halloween that's what I wanted to
say that's how I'm ending this one
usually I'm bad at ending the news
updates but this one I'm just gonna say
happy Halloween and then no one can say
it was a bad ending happy Halloween
[Music]